the best thing for small talk is to
recognize that especially on a date or
in a bar club they just want a vibe you
don't have to have topics it's supposed
to be fun playful world building what do
you mean by world building if she says
oh my god you went to jamaica i studied
abroad they'd be like oh my god
fantastic after this bar we're going to
the airport we're going to get on a
plane we're going to go scuba diving
we'll be there tomorrow morning we're
going to have to fund this so somehow
i'm going to have to take up a job
selling lucy cigarettes
on the street what i just created was
almost an improvisational comedy
scenario like we're going to go here
here's what's going to happen obviously
none of this is real if you lead with
here's my cool job i work at goldman
sachs that's incredibly boring i can't
tell you the number of guys in new york
i saw who started by handing out
business cards instead of doing this fun
stuff first and then they'll be like who
are you tell me about yourself and then
at that point the goldman sachs thing
actually comes in as a pattern interrupt
and you're like oh holy like he's
actually funny and interesting and he's
prepared to sell a loose cigarette and
he's got a job at an investment bank